idea what men look for so if you can
kind of learn what men look for I think
it's absolutely compromise I have a
question if you were today if you were
to date a man could he discipline your
child
that's really interesting I think
um
number one it depends as well about
you're not you're not a mother about age
I'm African as well and it depends what
you mean by discipline so do you mean
now so my son's nine at the moment so so
we're talking about right now yeah so
okay he's gonna be a teenager soon so
let's say let's say you you find a good
man
because otherwise he's not going to be
around myself okay okay yeah okay yeah
so you're dating seriously yeah and
remember like if if he's dating you
seriously he has to see what he's gonna
get in the marriage okay yeah and so
assuming that he's a good man you trust
his judgment would you allow him to
Discipline Your Child
um so what do you mean by discipline oh
she's like running through Billy's ass
okay number one I come I understand
cultures and stuff but I just discipline
put him in his place like if you're
doing something stupid like um like
Hands-On have you
it doesn't have to be physical it can be
verbally disciplining your child or
punishing him like so he's talking back
you know like teenagers do boys like I
have brothers they'd be doing some wild
[ __ ] so okay your your boy is
disrespecting him absolutely he can
discipline in the ways that we've spoken
about previously obviously me and my
partner would have the conversation you
would have a conversation let me say
something when we get to know each other
because my son needs to respect the so
let me say something right father role
model like I said I've done this I I
done it for like a Whole Decade and what
I found is the mother of the child that
you're with will always let you know
that that child's not yours right when
it comes to discipline whether it be a
conscious or a subconscious thing
they'll always let you know that that
child's not yours
hang on hang on so if so if and when it
was time for me to discipline and that
child was getting a little bit too you
know a little bit
there would be there would be a a line
of discipline that I knew I couldn't
cross that her father because her father
was still in her life her father could
cross that line but I couldn't right but
for me as a man of the household who
protected and provided for this
household I feel like I should be able
to those children are my children yeah I
agree with you I do able to discipline
the children the way I just my children
and that is one of the reasons again a
lot of the reasons why men
[Music]
stay straight and stay away from single
mothers because if a man is going to
become king or Emperor or head of the
household right he's going to want to
run that the way he wants to run it all
the time
but would you have would you have
conversation with your biological father
and how he's going to discipline his
child that's what I take that's like
taking part of his masculinity no no you
wouldn't not with her but I don't think
anybody really like to and people talk
about all kinds of stuff before it
happens but in this situation I'm
bringing a man into not just my life but
yeah so therefore we will have these
conversations before because obviously
it's important so I have a question what
if there is a disagreement he
disciplined your kid in a way that you
didn't agree with what would you do as
long as it's not a physical put a
physical aside so it was physical just
say it was physical what would you do
then obviously I would have the
conversation that that's not okay
explain why that's not okay um would all
deal with it so so we could yeah but see
this is like it's like a lack of
submission because submission is a
mission is trusting a guy's judgment
yeah and like I'm not like you actually
seem so nice I like you but like it's
like I feel like that that's going to be
hard for a guy because it's like you
have to pick and choose like what he can
and can't wait I know I completely
understand and agree with you on that
side but just for me with the physical
side I just feel like
um I wouldn't like I just can't do it
like don't touch my child I wouldn't
touch my child so exactly so kind of in
a way it kind of so I don't you're kind
of you're kind of in a way saying that
okay you may be his uh stepson or
whatever but he's not yours so you
already tell him this ain't your problem
yeah but that's what I'm saying you
can't you can't yeah you can nurture it
but there's a line which means you're
kind of in a way you're controlling him
which means he's never gonna have real
love for that child because you cannot
really you know but that's totally
different though that's violence that's
totally no but okay I'm giving them
example like this remember remember I
said he's a good man and you trust his
job okay
sometimes a different like my dad hit my
brother maybe maybe he hits you a little
bit my dad's a great team my mom beat me
with a spoon
right you know what yeah yeah she would
hit me with it I deserved it
[Music]
I stole from my uncle and she came and
said you stole all right you know one
thing here I believe as well that let's
say uh the father hit the child and the
child is maybe uh 12 or 13 and if the
child kind of exaggerated or lie I
guarantee you the mother's gonna believe
the child over the father can I say
something what what I wanted to go back
to is what you've done
without trying to do it because I like
to listen to people and a lot of the
time the subconscious mind comes out on
the conscious right you said my child
right so the fact that you called the
child your child he is going to know
that a child's not his right
if there was a biological as well I
think that is right so regardless so you
see this child as yours right and so
when somebody sees something as theirs
they act a certain way they they behave
in a certain way to let people know that
this is mine right this is it so this so
this is one of the reasons why as I said
a lot of men
think nah Single mother's not because
they don't want to say
they don't want to go into a situation
where someone's saying it's mine you
know the children is mine you don't do
it it's mine I feel like I would be like
that regardless and maybe that's just a
reflection of my character that maybe
now you pointed out I can realize maybe
I shouldn't speak in certain ways rather
than because I'd be happy it's not even
about speaking if me and you had a child
together I would still probably
chosen to use that word right so I need
to be mindful on my words right that's
kind of a lie though because let's let's
say you have a little kid like for you
as a woman you may smack him just a
little just a little there's you you
can't lie and say that you've never
touched your son just a little smack I
mean if she said okay she said she
hasn't she hasn't and let's say are you
from
let's say the farmers some people just
don't smack their children yeah yeah I
mean must be nice can I say something
yeah no do you know what this this side
here I will say actually baby girl you
know I love you right but I would say
maybe because of my African background
the way we look at respect and the way
we look at discipline is quite different
when it's an adult and there's a lack of
respect from a child the adult by Being
the adult by culture and I would say by
right can discipline that child and
discipline now is is this is what we're
not talking about there's discipline and
that is abuse and this is if there's
something that in your culture or that
in your personal life in just how you
are that you don't agree with you can
discuss this early on and said you know
what at this point like educating the
children I'm really not I'm trying to
not be violent at all because I have
that experience or from what I believe
is just not right so when something
really grave happens can we please try
and think of a better way to handle it
than to hate the child if it gets to a
point where a good man hits your child
because they and for good man to hit
your child it takes a lot right it takes
a lot then when it gets to that stage
actually it's not about my childhood so
that you need to get to the bottom of
the situation and understand what
happened and then you can also reinforce
the fact that that child needed to be
disciplined because at the end of the
day this now comes down to respect less
than oh this is my child your child
biological non-biological is respect you
know what I mean and I think that
discipline and respect is things that
are really important that actually
anyone should be able to do your kid
goes to school the school disciplines
your child your kid who's your teacher
who's the kids teacher yeah you teach
them in school and everything I love you
your teacher the teacher will tell the
child get out of my classroom you will
fruit you can go to detention stand
there and I feel like I can't really
speak on it too much because I haven't
experienced both sides I just have an
opinion on what I think and what I feel
and you know and that's it really so I'm
not saying that I'm like yeah right or
wrong in any way it's just my personal
life experience and I haven't you're
asking me questions that I haven't found
myself in a situation so I can only sort
of think quickly I only I only ask
because it's just good to think about
because it's just what it is I've
listened to me like I've listened to men
talk for so long that I just understand
like their point of view on a lot of
things and a lot of them like it's not
necessarily that they wouldn't date
single mothers um although a lot
wouldn't but like
a lot of it is like the problems that
come with it yeah like the baby daddy
like the the disciplining like like the
problems that Sarah was not expression
well and the would you allow someone to
like legally adopt your child
um what you mean so they're legally
their father yeah because the other
issue is like men will take on someone
else's kid put a decade and then they
break up and yeah yeah absolutely it
will be something I'll be open to I
would never say no but obviously that's
a separate situation but I just wouldn't
say no okay yeah
um I think
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible